voilà shalimar le clown salman rushdie
c'est chez plon est-ce que vous êtes
prêts pour une interview
outsider d'accord calm and rush duquel
défaut aimeriez vous avoir la cupidité
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir la gentillesse qu'est-ce qui
vous donnerait envie d'être trompé par
une femme au caractère
qu'est ce que l'avenir ne dira pas sur
hbo peut-être mon sens de l'humour on ne
sera jamais en quoi aimeriez-vous être
beaucoup plus mauvais la colère qui ne
voudriez vous pas avoir comme femme voix
quels sont les défauts qu'une femme doit
avoir pour vous séduire
la tolérance quelle est l'insulté qui
vous a fait le plus plaisir c'est la
portée par l'ayatollah comédie ce
qu'elle est le compliment qui vous
énerve le plus n'aimait pas le livre le
décrit les pièces pays quel est le talon
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir le talent
de d'intimider les jeux quelle est la
question qu il ne faut pas que je vous
pose cela faisait pas qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez que quelqu'un vous volent
peut-être mon passé quelle est la
meilleure mauvaises critiques qu'on vous
ait fait voyant mon fils une femme a dit
lors quand j'écris un livre pour enfants
qu'ils étaient trop lents et que les
gens pourraient sans mouiller alors je
dirais et crime un rythme plus rapide
merci
c'est publié chez plon mesdames
messieurs